[Music]
on today's show we talked to a woman
who's struggling to unify a blended
family we also talked to a woman of
three young kids who wants to be a
police officer and she wants to know how
that's going to affect her family
and man i go off on the new mental
health days for kids stay tuned
[Music]
what's up
it's john with the dr john dolone's
shirt there's no reason to be yelling
john none
hope you're doing well talking about
mental health relationships all of it i
am trying to pump myself up
man the uh if you're listening to this
it's gonna be a few weeks out so who
knows what the world would look like by
the time this actually hits the air but
um the
the ukraine invasion happened a day or
two ago and it's been heavy on my heart
watching those
man it's just been hot tough man so who
knows by the time this we listen to this
the world's gonna look very different so
either up or down and um
hearts heavy on this one so i'm gonna do
my best to holler and yell and we're
gonna walk alongside some folks doing
hard stuff and i'm grateful that you're
with us if you want to be on this show
give me a buzz at 1-844-693-3291
it's
1-844-693-3291 or go to johndaloni.com
ask and let's go to sarah in the city of
angels los angeles what's up sarah
not much how's it going we are
rocking onto the break we're not i'm
just sitting here in a studio it's kind
of kind of being lame how are you
i'm good thanks
uh i have a question for you surrounding
our family identity um meaning what
should we call ourselves
um i hear you on the show you love my
nicknames is that what you're calling
for
i do i don't know what to call myself
our family name um so i hear you talk on
the show a lot about you know the family
values and drawing them up and then
you'll say things like we're the
delonies and deloney's are people who
xyz yes um and we don't all have the
same last name
so i don't really know what to call us
and how to anchor those things and it
comes up
in other ways too like what to put on
christmas cards and things like that so
why separate last names
so um
sorry i get emotional about it no that's
cool man i'm glad that you called
it would have been way funner just to
come up with some nicknames i'm so good
at just
ruthless nicknames but that's not that's
not why you start why you're calling so
um yeah take your time no problem at all
so yeah why do you have different names
um
so i'm married to my husband who's
wonderful and it's definitely the father
of all three of our kids but he's only
the biological father of our six months
old okay and we i have a six and eight
year old whose father died i'm so sorry
what was his name
dan dan
good guy
great guy yeah
when did they where when did dan pass
away
um almost seven years ago now seven
years ago that's still right there on
top of your heart isn't it
yep yeah how did he pass away
um a heart arrhythmia sudden totally
unexpected oh man i'm so sorry
and so how did you meet this new guy
um at work
oh gross
yeah i know
he's wonderful we're all in love it's
great
that's so great i knew you're going to
make fun of us no i don't know
i'm absolutely not at all um
one of my
most important men in my life very
similar situation he um married a great
woman whose husband passed away suddenly
just completely unexpectedly and they
have two wonderful kids and there's
still that
thing right that my life is because of
right and so
those are challenging just messy things
to walk through and so you've decided
your kids your your two kids that were
biologic
biological children of day and have kept
his last name
yeah
we're still really involved with his
family and that's important to them and
the kids have not expressed any desire
to change their last name so at this
point we're they're keeping their their
dad's last name
their original dad's last name and
i i just struggle a little bit i think
because i had my parents last name
growing up my husband had his parents
last name growing up and there's some
family pride behind it and to say we are
the let's say quote-unquote smith's
family yeah and there's something behind
that you know
how honest do you want me to be with you
brutal go for it come on sarah
not super brutal hey it can't get any
worse than the guy that you're you know
have kids with dropping dead on you
well played i see what you did there
um
i've talked to you for like two minutes
now okay
and
my
impulse this is just from my guts
is that you haven't let dan go
and my guts is says
you have a picture of family
that is still haunting you because your
new family that you love dearly make no
mistake
that you love dearly doesn't look like
that old picture
and you are still hanging on to that old
picture
while living in another photo
and your body can't reconcile
one foot here and one foot here or more
more damning half your heart here and
half your heart here
right
and
because what we're talking about when it
comes to names is semantics i mean you
could put like the dodgers or whatever
other nonsense team you have there in
los angeles you call it the ponies the
frogs the you know the hip-hop artist i
don't care what you call it it could be
anything
but this isn't about a name
this is about you not letting dan go
and this is about you not fully being
this is what my family looks like now
and when whatever and two last names
seven last names who cares about the
names
it's about you leaning into
we have to come up with who we are and
you still see we as but also him
right
and so what i'm telling you is dan will
always have a place in your heart you'll
see his face as those kids get older and
older and older you'll see his attitudes
and the laugh that he had and the eye
crinkles that he had you'll see that
stuff forever
fully there and you got to let dan go
right and you have to take ownership of
your new story your new picture your new
whatever this is and then call it
whatever crap you want to
yeah i agree a hundred percent ring true
still work for me
it does it does
and i know it seems like semantics and
silly
a name is powerful right and they look
at what's happening in russia and
ukraine today like you're russians no
we're not right a name is everything
it's so don't hear me be dismissive of
that
yeah but when you come out i agree
there's probably more to it i just also
have this other thing going on too
what's the other thing
meaning that
my kids when we say we are the smith
family let's say they they feel left out
when we try to
use one name i guess you know
okay
do they feel that or do you feel that
on their behalf
no definitely my oldest is vocal about
it okay that he feels left out when we
use the family name that's my husband
and i's name and the baby's name but he
doesn't want to change his name
he doesn't want to change his name and
he in fact when he was very upset that i
was changing my name when i got married
and also um kind of wanted my husband to
change his last name to dan's last name
how old how old is this he wasn't gonna
happen eight yeah
so be very careful about letting an
eight-year-old's feelings dictate yours
right because they're eight and you've
heard me say this a thousand times like
there's a reason why we don't let
eight-year-olds
you know drive cars and buy beer and
vote because they're eight
and of course everything in his body and
heart and mind wants to keep things the
way they were i don't want to forget dad
i've got that i'm going to hang on to
that
and at the same time
um anything that looks new to his little
body is a threat
because everything he knew is different
now everything he knows is different now
and so
i mean i would honor that hug him
through that
and feel those like man i'm i hear that
you feel left out and my heart's broken
that you feel left out because you're
part of this just because your name is
remaining jones
you're you're a member of the smith
family
or i like that you're a member of the
joan smith family right with i'll stick
a hyphen in there for you if that's what
you need right but you're here you're in
this gang and in fact here's what's
gonna happen if he's if he
follows if he tracks
he's gonna pull
on the rope he's gonna pull on that
tether and see how tight see if you're
gonna leave too
see if this new guy's gonna leave too
and he's gonna yank and pull and kick
and bite and claw and see if his little
uh muscles
can push away too cause it's happened
once before
and that's just his sweet beautiful
little body trying to protect him
oh yeah he definitely does that yeah i
mean it's totally normal it's
heartbreaking and it's awful and that's
the trauma of losing somebody so
important in your life right
and my guess is you probably do the same
thing just differently
right
i don't know what that looks like but
have you ever sat down and written dan a
letter yet
oh yeah plenty of times how did that go
tell us about it
it's it's good it's cathartic i mean i
get it from the very beginning like i
said it's been nearly seven years now so
have you ever told him how pissed off
you are adam
oh yeah good time good
good
so yeah i think continuing to work
through it but
i would love to see you grieve and
have some sort of something where you
let dan go
and
man
it's always gonna be a part of you but
honor your kids and then come up with a
name and if it's the jones typhon smith
name for the for a couple of years okay
i'm not gonna lose sleep over that um
it's more important to do that to the
unity exercise which i mean i would love
to have the joan smith values would be
great
um right and just throw a hyphen up
there is that something y'all can do
uh yeah i think so
i think so and
here's what would be real important
invite your two young ones dan's kids
invite them to participate in this not
only participate but to take some major
ownership in this who are we all good
yeah that's what i like that's what i
liked about it when you talk about it on
the show is having the kids participate
have some buy-in yeah and even if they
say what are some things that um
dan what are what are some things that
your
original what are some things he would
have wanted on this list
because here's the thing
he's
half of your kids are him
right and so man bring him bring dan is
to be a part of this thing and i know
that's like i'm talking out of both
sides of my mouth let him go but your
kids can never let them go half of half
of them is dan right so
what are some things that dan dan dad
would want you to put in here right to
put on this form to to to put as a part
of our values what's something that that
meant that values to that and they may
not know or they may make it up
something they don't have a lot of
memories of him because one's only eight
right he's one years old um but you can
bring some stuff he loved laughter
he loved joy he loved respecting other
people he loved different opinions and
he loved you know wrestle whatever the
things are add those things are let them
know that the other half with that that
rests within them is
strong and good and you let that half
let him go let him go and then begin to
truly live into that picture that you
have i'm so i'm man i'm makes my heart
feel good that you've been writing
letters for years that's fantastic
[Music]
maybe it's time to write the letter that
says it's time for me to let you go
i got two little boys to raise and
another six month old by this other guy
who's pretty awesome by the way but i
met him at work and gross but
here we are in the news story
thank you so much for your call we'll be
right back
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else but when
it comes to making time for vacation for
exercise for talking with a mentor for
sleep even going to therapy
we don't do it and we don't even realize
they won't even think about it
you are worth it
this month better help online therapy
wants to remind you that you are
important
that you are worth being well and
therapy is a super important way you can
show up for yourself
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone even live chat
sessions with your therapist you don't
even have to see anyone on a camera if
you don't want to it's more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours today dr john daloni show
listeners get 10 off their first month
so decide to invest in yourself you are
worth it and go to
betterhelp.com to get 10 percent off
that's betterhelp.com
all right we are back let's go to
mechalecha high mecha heidi ho in
madison what's up madison
hi what are you doing
i'm just hiding in my closet from my kid
dude there's so many things i could say
that i'm not even going to say them how
in the world are you doing okay
i'm doing well how are you i'm just
just getting it so what's up
so i am calling because i want to become
a police officer
but i'm also concerned because i have
three kids
ah okay so talk to me about it tell me
more
so i have a six-year-old a
two-year-old and a nine-month-old
and
i always wanted to be a police officer
but i'm also concerned for you know my
safety like what's gonna happen if
something happens to me and
you know with the schedule and the
demand of the job like will i also be
able to be a good mom i guess then
i'm afraid they're going to respect me
for
picking that career in bed it's going to
demand a lot of me gotcha man
they are so lucky to have you that's
incredible um tell me about their their
dad
uh so he is a nurse
at the veterans hospital
um and he works in the psychiatric unit
at the metro hospital
and you uh you were two people
come like committed to service aren't
you
yes i guess you can say that he he was
in the military before that and now he's
a nurse now i'm saying both of you are
committed to service so why why be a
police officer why do you wanna do that
job
i don't know and i knew you were gonna
ask that and i don't have an answer you
don't you don't have to give me one just
you can just say i'm gonna go i'm gonna
go do it that's that's all good but i
think
you know like i know when i talk to my
dad
he always jokes with me and he goes you
know remember when you were little you
always say you wanted to be a police
officer
and like the end goal of it is i want to
be a homicide detective
dude that's what my dad was
yeah and that's why i'm like
he's like the perfect person to call you
know
you don't have both sides so here is all
of it okay i'm gonna give you all of
that
um
number one
being a police officer is hard
like take your kids out of it this is
just me talking to my friend heidi being
a police officer is hard
it's hard it's hard emotionally it's
hard psychologically it's hard
spiritually it's hard practically right
if you are at a place that runs 412s and
then you have three days off but those
12-hour shifts are exhausting right and
then you get up and do it again you get
up and do it again
um
that's a job that nobody ever calls you
because they're having a good day
right um some people come to if you work
at burger king some people come through
the line they're having a great day and
some people are coming through in line
and they're having a medium day when
you're a police officer you're always
responding to people's worst parts of
their day that's just what you do
and so that just takes a toll on you
um
and then there's the family aspect of it
the family part's hard right yeah all
that's real
and
we've bought into this cultural myth
that
our kids are our purpose
they are quote-unquote everything
and service opportunities and financial
everything
time um
mission all those things have to come in
service to
these shiny little toys we now have
called kids and that is a relatively
recent development in human history
and so what i would tell you is this i
was the son of a homicide detective i
missed the first three years when he
worked narc and he was um like you know
he was undercover and he i missed all
that and that's just me being honest
i can imagine those days would be hard
back then it was i think you had to do
three years before you could start
testing for to be a detective right so
there is some part of this that you'll
have to put in on the beat and that'll
just be hard
it'll be tough not to mention your
husband's a trauma nurse right in a
psychiatric unit that's real hard too
and so there will be parts of this
journey
that a
two-year-old it won't compute a
six-year-old won't compute right
what i will tell you on a long enough
timeline number one if you become a
detective and that's where you
ultimately end up you do have more i
don't say flexibility because if there's
a big case to be solved there's a case
to be solved and it's all hands on deck
and it's 24 hours and all that
but you do have more what i call
professional flexibility right i have
very vivid memories of my dad showing up
not in a cop uniform but in a suit right
so he was able to make my stuff and he
was at home for dinner and and so i've
got some very vivid memories of that
um so it would be more conducive once
you get into law enforcement
administration to into a family life so
it should be different hard but but you
can do it um
what i will tell you is this
that his service my dad's and this again
this is n equals one this is just me
i wouldn't trade his service for
anything
the example it set for me on my
responsibility not just to my two kids
but to all of the kids in my
neighborhood and in my community and
when somebody's hurting or somebody's
been shot and killed my job is to go in
not run
that when um there is hard hard things
that need to be done like someone needs
to go sit with that widow
you go sit with that widow
you put the video game controllers down
and you go help out in your local
community right
those are lessons that i learned that
were meta lessons from him watching him
put on his bulletproof vest when he had
to go to a hostage negotiation um
somebody was going to jump off a
building and they called him it like
watching him leave the house to go do
those things and then him he was brave
and he talked to me about them kind of
what he you know age-appropriately what
he's going through and what he
experienced
man i wouldn't trade that for anything
because i got to see what character
looks like and what hardness looks like
and what um service truly looks like
so my my
my words of wisdom to you or this
yes it's gonna be hard
and hard doesn't mean it's not worth it
what you have to decide is do we have
child care coverage do we have people in
our do we have family do we have um
sitters do we have people who could get
our kids to and from especially in the
first 36 months while you have to go
through
you know the academy and go through all
of the running the beats and they're
going to give you the worst shifts right
you're going to have the 11 p.m to 3 a.m
shifts and
um wait could you have a season in your
life where you've got care and coverage
where you can do that
um
and yeah i think
i mean i say go for it and i know if
that's in your heart and that's
something you want to do i say go for it
um will your children quote unquote
suffer yeah it will be hard on them it
really will
um actually i take that back will they
suffer no will it be really hard on them
and they'll be they'll miss their mom
abso freaking lutely and you hope they
will right you hope they would miss
their mom yeah um
hopefully you and your husband here's
the thing i'll tell you this i'm more
concerned about your marriage
okay um being married to a cop's heart
it just is my mom was when i told my mom
i wanted to be a police officer someday
when i wanted to join the fbi back when
i was in college um she asked me not to
not for me but for the sake of my wife
my future spouse that i didn't even have
yet um and she said that's hard so
you and your husband will have to be in
really intentional constant
communication which is often not the
gift of a nurse or a cop right so you're
gonna have to work together on that um
to be very intentional about staying
connected especially over the three four
years that you're running the beat um
and and your husband's continuing to
live in the lives of trauma of other
people right um but man you handle your
marriage well your kids will stay
tethered in there and they'll get a
ringside seat to what love and service
actually looks like i think that'll be
that could be a beautiful story
how does that sound were you hoping i
tell you no don't do it
um
i i was
you know just
i
knew that's what it was i mean i know
that like i can make my decisions based
on like my kids all the time
you know but i think it's a mom that's
like a horror thing you know oh it's
brutal right
does it have to be this year
when you have a nine month old can you
wait
18 months you know what i mean can you
wait a minute and then do try then so is
it something has to happen with a
newborn in the house or is it what's the
impetus for the emergency right now
i so we actually have the help for child
care which is not always available for
us
so i think like
um
having that available will make it much
easier because like my mom will be here
helping beautiful that's to me that's
best case scenario that grandma's there
or granddad's there to help right or
aunt whoever that that to me is best
case scenario because then you've got
family leaning into family i think
that's fantastic
and so that's why you know my husband
when i told them that the academy was
actually
recruiting for
next the upcoming year
he was like you know you should do it
you always he goes the eight years we've
been married that's all you talked about
he's like i'm sick of hearing it heidi
he goes just do it because i don't want
you to like look back and be like i
never did it i've always talked about it
but never did it yeah so and he goes
then it's the perfect time and he goes
we have to help which we never did
before it's like it's all fallen into
places and he goes and i think you're
gonna regret not doing it for the sake
of the kids yeah and so i think
that's why i'm like deciding to do it
on planet earth
you have outsourced one vote
and it feels like everybody's got
uh a guy gets to speak into this what
does mom think what does dad think i'll
tell you i i don't like it's cool it's
respectful to listen to their opinion
they don't get a vote
the one person that gets a vote besides
you is your husband
yeah right and if you've given one or
two or three or four really close sister
or friends votes too their votes matter
also but your husband's vote counts
above all else
and so if you're in and he's in and
y'all have family help yeah go for it go
serve your community go be a a shining
star to your children
um for what service and love look like
and
hold this loosely if you get four months
into the academy and say
i
this sounded great
but i want to be a mom
then you hold your head up high and put
your badge on the counter and put your
gun on the counter and go be with your
children and you'll you'll be a hero
there too right
don't ever box yourself into an either
or scenario
um but i think you can love your kids
deeply and um
i i don't i don't regret a day of my
dad's service i'm really grateful that i
got to have that example and that will
pay dividends that his example will
reverberate through
his family tree which is now my family
tree which is in my local communities
wherever i happen to live
yeah you can be a gift i'm i'm grateful
for your you and your husband and your
service hearts man it's really
incredible
thank you you just squeeze those little
knucklehead of kids squeeze them until
their guts hurt let them know their mama
loves loves loves loves loves them
we'll be right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in the mls consumer access dot org
equal housing lender 1749 mallory lane
suite 100 brentwood tennessee 37027
programs are for select loan types only
and are not available in all states or
locations
all right we are
back
um
oh the horse noises are back
that's how you know what's coming
um
i got asked recently i was on an
interview and i'm not talking to anybody
i'm just talking to you the listener
talking to myself talking to my family
um i got asked on an interview recently
and there's been some media discussion
about this
about this idea of mental health days in
schools
meaning
kids should not only get sick days but
they should also be able to declare a
mental health day
or two days or three days whatever that
looks like and we're seeing states all
across the country
implement mental health days
and i was asked my opinion on it
and i had a visceral response that is
usually is unlike me
um and so full disclosure
one i'm uh the my heart's broken with
the
uh russian news it's killing me
thinking of i'm watching these videos of
these
young fathers kissing their daughter or
their son goodbye
um those 13 guys that were left out you
know hung out there in that island i
mean i'm watching these stories and i've
just been replaying in my mind over and
over and over
man what would it be like to
kiss my daughter goodbye and my son
goodbye and put them to my wife in a car
and then put on some
leather
whole ridden
makeshift uh
bulletproof vest
and then get with my neighbors and go
out and
stare down a ruthless murderous enemy
i'm just thinking about what that's got
to be like
and
we can all talk about courage and
i got mean social media posts but
right now as i'm recording this
it's happening in real time it's real
people saying i'm staying
um
so that's weighing on me and so some of
my response to that question about
mental health days and again this is all
woven together about mental health days
was
because i'm tired and i don't like what
i'm watching i don't like what i'm
seeing
but also because a mental health day if
you ask me like what do i think about it
it's an abdication of responsibility
so let me say out front yeah dude
absolutely should kids have mental
health days sure
fine i happen to believe that as a
parent of two kids in a public school
the public school has absolutely zero
business asking me
or
having input over where i take my kids
that's my responsibility if i come pick
my kids up from school i don't have to
tell you where we're going you're not my
dad you're not my mom
i don't like that i also having worked
in public schools
both public high schools been a k
through f i was a k-5 teacher for a year
i've worked in public university like
i also know there are parents who just
don't show up let their kids run the
streets all day so i get it i get that
too somebody's got to make some rules
and i get it
so sure kids say hey i'm i'm literally
crumbling under the weight of this of
school of home of all this sure let them
stay home no problem with that
but here's what pisses me off
you want to help kids mental health
it's not going to come to a couple of
days off like yeah that's what a
political nonsense like we got a victory
for kids mental health bull crap you
want to help kids mental health how
about you stop starting school at 6 45
a.m
let these children sleep
how about you serve them food that's not
trash how about my son at school has
silent lunches because they don't let
middle schoolers talk in the lunchroom
because it's too
loud how about you let kids communicate
with each other how about you put recess
back in and let their bodies move
let them compete and have fun and be
silly and fall down and scrape their
knees and their elbows and break a bone
and have to rally around each other and
come back
how about you don't put kids in jail if
they push each other
how about you have classes in school
that teach emotional and socio-psycho
social psycho psychosocial development
excuse me
how about you have classes in school
that teach kids hey this is what the
emotion you're feeling is here's how to
create some space between you and that
emotion and here's how to react
because here's what happens on a mental
health day that kid's gonna go home and
sit on their phone for eight hours and
scroll social media
or they're gonna pick up video game
controllers or they're gonna just stay
in bed
you wanna help kids mental health
parents
stop stop
stop putting your job over your kid
stop putting
um
like easy act like uh hey it's just
simpler let's just easier let's just do
that
hey here's a digital babysitter kids
cause i'm too caught up in my own shows
how about hey kids no you don't have
social media because i see the data and
i'm not gonna give you drugs and i'm not
gonna give you comparison tools at the
age of seven or twelve or fourteen
that's gonna permanently alter your
brain chemistry how about that
how about instead of well uh daddy needs
some shut up how about you invite some
friends over take your kids fishing
how about you stop raging out and
screaming and yelling at little league
games and at dance recitals
how about you kick a soccer ball with
your kids
how about you put down the news and your
rage and your anger and your phones
and get connected with your children
and i had to work late last night
i was up here late
my boss called the meeting talking about
media we're doing a bunch of stuff i got
a book coming out so i'm up before
god himself and i was out late last
night
and i got home
and
i went down i went over to
open my kids doors and i
said quick prayer over them i tell them
goodnight and i love them i say it out
loud even though i know they're asleep
and when you know it my stinking
six-year-old daughter's
her light was still on she was reading a
book
my first thought was what are you doing
but i looked at her we made sleepy eye
contact
and i said
in a quiet voice
i challenge you to a game of air hockey
now
and she looked at me funny and said now
and i said
if you want to get crushed bring it
and she grinned from ear to ear and
kicked off those covers with both feet
and we snuck down to the basement
and we had this
junky air hockey table
and she kicked my butt seven ways to
sunday in our air hockey and we played
for five minutes
and we laughed
and we hugged and we talked to daddy
daughter trash
and she told me some story about
something that happened at school
and then on the way back
i took a knee and she
jumped up on my back and i carried her
up the stairs and put her to bed and
turned the lights off and kissed her
goodnight and said i love you baby
five minutes
do you want to fix children's mental
health plug-in
to your kids not to some stupid device
sure couple days man
absolutely we need to take better care
of our kids
but schools you want to be serious about
it
[Music]
stop threatening first graders with
their college entrance
stop focusing on tests and start
focusing on learning stop focusing on
connection start focusing on
body movement and psychology
relationship
instead of your precious little test
scores
parents want to help kids mental health
fix your marriages connect with your
kids put down the devices
be parents and create boundaries and
protection for your kids
[Music]
that's all i got to say about that we'll
be right back
[Music]
for the past two decades i've worked
with students parents those on the
margins and those who seem to have
everything i've met with law enforcement
military folks struggling single moms
company presidents and everybody in
between and there is one thread that
weaves through all of these different
people that you
me we
are so
lonely we don't have real in-depth safe
relationships and hear me say this you
cannot be well alone
you can't do life by yourself you got to
get connected to real life people and
have deep
relationships i'm talking relationships
where you can be yourself share hard
things and know you'll show up for one
another in my new book own your past
change your future we'll walk through a
not so complicated approach to
relationships mental health and wellness
and getting connected because it's a key
part of living a good life you'll learn
why shallowness and loneliness are so
dangerous you'll even learn how to start
making real friends so go to
johndaloney.com to take the next step
towards wellness that's own your past
change your future at johndaloni.com
all right hey we're back for those of
you who are still with us i guess
there's about six of you now i think i
just cut our audience in half
um
hey we had a call a few weeks ago um
somebody called in and said they thought
that their friend might be abusing
children
and his kid his friend worked at a
daycare told him about some past stuff
some history stuff had some photographs
then we got as we dug into the story a
little bit and pulled on the threads
uh you know ended up
pretty pretty certain something was
going down so just as a reminder to
everybody as soon as that call was over
we called the authorities in that
community let them know i'm going to
report that every single time
and i should have said that on that
episode and i didn't but also we got an
email back
and this is just part of the email from
the guy who called i want to let you
know um
it's a brave strong man
and i'm grateful for him here's what he
writes he writes hi kelly i want to give
you all an update on this situation on
his friend
first i'm so thankful impressed and glad
that y'all followed up on this like i
said we did call the police in that
local community and by the way we called
the anyway let's go from there
he goes on to say he had a hard
conversation
asked hard questions and it got heated
between him and a close friend
he put the health and safety of these
kids ahead of a friendship
hard and brave
he then filed a report with the
authorities and he went above and beyond
and he notified the workplace we all
know that authorities sometimes
unfortunately they can't respond and
proactive they have to respond in
response too right they gotta wait till
somebody actually does a thing
so what did this guy do he called the
workplace said hey by the way one of
your employees has taken pictures of
children he shouldn't be there and i
know his past history he shouldn't be
there
he writes
this is probably going to cost me my
friendship
he i'll just read exactly what he writes
again thank you for facilitating and
producing this and to john for his
guidance and empowerment to have this
conversation
was the hardest thing i've ever had to
do and it might cost some friendships
and it could hurt someone i do care
about but if it protects one single
child from a lifetime of trauma it is
worth it
absolutely
what a brave man
thank you for doing this and let his
bravery be a signpost be a path in the
wilderness for all of us facing hard
conversations hard decisions hard
choices
it's gonna cost your friends it's gonna
cost you community it's gonna cost you
and it's still right
all right as we wrap up today's show man
um let's do this whole song there ben so
it's one of the greatest songs i've
written by one of the top songwriters in
the world i think frank turner the
song's called be more kind
and it goes like this
history's been leaning on me lately i
can feel the future breathing down my
neck and all the things i thought were
true when i was young and you were too
turned out to be broken and i don't know
what comes next
in a world that's decided it's going to
lose its mind
be more kind my friends try to be more
kind
they've started raising walls around the
world now like hackles raised upon a
cornered cat on the borders in our heads
between things that can and can't be
said we've stopped talking to each other
and there's something wrong with that so
before you go out searching don't decide
what you will find be more kind my
friends try to be more kind
and you should know you're not alone and
the trouble comes and trouble goes how
this ends no one knows so hold on tight
when the wind blows the wind blew us
both both of us to sand and sea and
where the dry land stands is hard to say
and as the current drags us by the shore
we can no longer say for sure who's
drowning or if they can be saved but
when you're out there floundering like a
lighthouse i will shine be more kind my
friends try to be more kind like a
beacon reaching out to you and yours
from me and mine be more kind my friends
try to be more kind we'll see you soon i
love you guys